i wanted to update my video entitled
keto on steroids
so this is the version of the ketogenic
diet that's very very strict and it's
for those people
that need to drop weight maybe for a
wedding or a situation
or you're at a plateau situation and you
need to jump start your program
okay first thing we're going to talk
about is these things right here they're
called
carbs normally you would
be given a range between 30
to 50 grams of carbs per day we're gonna
bring that down to five
no more than five carbs per day okay
so best way to do it is through mainly
vegetables now if we take a look at the
total carbs and this is per cup
total carb is seven and then net net
carb is three
so if you do spinach
all you can do in a given day is do a
little more than one cup
right because you want to you want to
keep it within five grams
but look at lettuce right here 0.5
so you could do 10 cups of lettuce that
would be
better than spinach avocado you can do a
little more than two cups of avocado
right asparagus look at that point three
so you can do a good amount of asparagus
or olives you can do maybe a little more
than a cup and a half
mushrooms you can do several cups swiss
chard you could do quite a bit
zucchini you can do a couple cups
arugula you can do more
celery you can do a good amount and then
you have bok choy
and then radish and watercress so so
on this program there are things that
are very very important
and things that are moderately important
and less important
this up here is very very important to
keep these carbs below
5 grams per day not per meal and so
really
pay attention to the neck carbs and how
many you can get away with
to keep this under 5 grams obviously
like the vegetables right here
lettuce asparagus
swiss chard arugula
bok choy watercress it's probably
the best right here is better because
you can consume more of it that means
you're going to get vitamin c you're
going to get more nutrients you're going
to get more minerals
from that food but it's a lot of fiber
as well
so this is number one right here let's
talk about proteins
it's very important that you don't
overdo it with protein you don't want to
go over seven
or maybe eight ounces for certain
individuals
but usually between three to seven
ounces
okay now what you're going to be doing
is you're going to
be doing omad one meal a day so this is
all the protein that you're going to
consume in a given day if you consume
too much protein okay your body just
basically breaks it down and turns into
glucose
that's what happens so that can actually
raise insulin so we keep it
moderate we're going to be totally fine
the key is having a fattier type of
protein why because that'll keep insulin
lower as well like for example on eggs
you don't want to do just egg whites you
want to eat do the whole egg
the yolk as well salmon is the ideal
fish
there's a lot of other fatty fish too
you can consume but this is perfect
okay summer sausage has more fat in it
just make sure there's no dextrose in
there
i just did a video on this i'll put a
link down
below hamburger is better than steak
because most steak is fairly on the lean
side there are certain steaks that are
fattier
but hamburger is a bit fattier and this
is why i would recommend hamburger over
other types of
meats okay eggs duck eggs would be
better than chicken eggs because they're
fattier
shellfish would be good pork
or lamb of course from the farmer's
market not from the local 7-eleven
and sausage you want to get the sausage
that has the most
fat all right this is your protein now
let's get to the fat
of course there's a lot of fat with this
protein right here
but the acceptable fats would be the
olive oil extra virgin the real stuff
butter coconut oil lard or tallow
now here's the thing you're gonna put
some olive oil on your salad dressing
you can cook with it
with butter you can actually put some on
your vegetables
and you can also cook with it coconut
oil
you can cook with it lard you can cook
with it
tallow you can cook with it but i don't
want you to add a lot
more fat to this meal in other words
i don't recommend doing the keto
desserts where you're making these
fat bombs not on this program
macadamia nuts and pecans
why because they are the fattiest
nut look at the ratio it's like 11.5
fat to one protein so it's 11.5
times greater in fat than protein
amazing
pecan is seven times greater fat than
protein now peanuts actually have the
most protein and the lowest fat but
that's a legume the only thing with
these two nuts is you're going to have
to look
at the carbs because one ounce is about
1.5 grams of net carb
so that has to be added into this
calculation right here
and that will kind of tell you the
volume of how many
of these nuts you can have pecans
look at this 1.3 gram net carb
per ounce so you have to add that to
your
your calculation one more
fat but it's really a combination of fat
and protein but it's actually
pretty fatty it's cod liver not cod
liver oil you can buy it in a can
and it's five times as much fat to
protein
and you can do this as your fat you're
going to be very very
satisfied and plus it has dha
big time it has epa which are which
are two omega-3 fatty acids it has
vitamin d
it has vitamin a it's going to be
extremely satisfying
you probably can consume like a half a
can and that will
you'll be very very satisfied okay no
dairy
too high in carbs no berries no keto
desserts
no mct oil why
because your body is going to burn this
more than your own
fat and you will be in ketosis
but if your goal is to lose weight just
mix this for right now
coffee keep it down to like one maybe
two per day
you can do tea through the day herbal
teas totally fine
of course don't put sugar in your coffee
electrolytes very very important
because you're going to be doing one
meal a day
and you want to make sure you get all of
your nutrients
b vitamins nutritional yeast is a good
source a lot if not
most of the b vitamins are water soluble
so that means you don't store them for
very long so if you're not taking them
you can end up with a deficiency
vitamin d unless you get sun
or you're consuming the cod liver
cod liver oil is a good source of
vitamin d
number five sea salt
you need between one to one and a half
teaspoons per
day so you're gonna have to either
figure out how to put it on your meal
your one meal a day
or even mix it with a little water slug
it down and then drink some water
very important because you're gonna need
that to prevent fatigue
and lethargy and even keto flu
so you're gonna do one meal a day and
every two weeks
you're gonna do a 48-hour fast this is
called
periodic prolonged fasting it's gonna
give your body a
huge jump start now exercise
okay twice a week the exercise should be
intense
it should be full body ideally to the
point where you're sweating and you're
working
multiple muscle groups and that's your
high intensity compound resistant type
exercise
twice a week spread it out on the off
days
you're going to be doing long walks at
least 45 minutes to keep the stress down
ideally exercise during your fasting
period
maybe like in the morning if you're
going to eat at night it's not an
absolute necessity but if you can
exercise in a fasting state
you can really spike that growth hormone
okay sleep this right here
is another one of those really important
things you want to go to bed a little
bit earlier
i personally go to bed at nine o'clock
okay i get up really early but i like to
go to bed at nine
um it seems to work occasionally i might
even take a little
power nap if you're not sleeping well
you should take some type of sleep aid
to assist yourself i'm talking a natural
type of sleep aid
no watching the news you're going to
feel
better just from that in fact that might
make you lose weight just by
avoiding that cortisol spike
keep your stress as low as possible
pick your friends wisely get some new
friends
don't hang around with anyone that is
too negative sun would be
very very good if there is sun out
that'll be more vitamin d
and also there's other benefits of being
out in the sun as well as being out in
nature
very very therapeutic all right there
you have it this is the keto and
steroids so
some people need to work up to this some
people could just jump right in
it really depends on where you're at and
how motivated you are but this will
definitely take your results
to a whole new level
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today